it's tense on the Korean Peninsula he
said you're ready to fight tonight yes
always fight tonight fight together
quite strong everyday 24/7 words radical
North Korean leader Kim jong-un and
president Trump are exchanging heated
threats on the South Korean and US
soldiers telling us not to film now the
South Korean government is installing
one of the u.s. military's most advanced
missile defense systems called bad in a
remote village despite ongoing I
[Music]
wouldn't be here yet you know I to
negate it
yeah it's you gotta move I am young
laude white or wrong you know I don't
think it is it's one of the three types
and look up as we have this is our
attack helicopter yeah aged 64 Apache
got a large capability of attack
platforms here in the combat aviation
brigade you know this is one of our
primary instruments if we had to fight
tonight we visited the US Army's new
base in South Korea just days after
President Trump made this notorious
threat to North Korea they will be met
with fire and fury like the world has
never seen at 3,400 acres camp humphreys
as one of the u.s. military's largest
overseas construction projects ever
located strategically out of range of
North Korea's rocket integers it's also
home to the Eighth Army which has gotten
a lot of attention since North Korea
recently tested two intercontinental
ballistic missiles that may be able to
reach the US
you guys say you're ready to fight
tonight what does that look like so it
means we have every leader every soldier
every aviator in this brigade that's
ready to jump on the right piece of
equipment whether that's a truck or a
helicopter and go execute their required
mission at a moment's notice over in the
United States right now people are
really paying attention to North Korea
and they're very freaked out about the
possibility of a nuclear war breaking
out is that sort of heightened panic
something that you guys are experiencing
here as well so we obviously are attuned
to some of the attention but for us it's
it's business as usual if the president
requires us to fight tonight and he
makes the call then he can trust it that
his soldiers here in Korea are ready to
support us and support this important
alliance that they've worked hard
South Korea becomes a battleground as
communists from the north invade the
southern Republic at a dozen points the
US has had a permanent military presence
in South Korea since it helped the
country fight the Korean War in 1950 the
war ended in armistice three years later
but there was never a peace treaty so
the countries are still technically at
war today there are 28 thousand US
troops in South Korea the third largest
US military presence overseas after
Japan and Germany Camp Humphreys was
recently relocated from an older base in
the middle of Seoul just 40 miles from
the border with North Korea North
Korea's government criticized the move
saying it shows that US has intention to
permanently occupy the Korean Peninsula
I know you guys do regular military
exercises with the South Korean military
which North Korea calls a provocation
and a rehearsal to invade what's your
perspective on that what do you call
these during exercises I call them
improving readiness exercises and really
when you're part of an alliance you have
a joint responsibility to collectively
build your readiness on both sides in an
off-camera briefing a high-ranking Army
official told us that should North Korea
use chemical or nuclear weapons the army
knows where they're stored and is
prepared to invade the country in order
to neutralize them at the same time the
North Korean government maintains they
need nukes to deter the threat of
invasion and an overthrow of Kim Jong
moon just 50 miles from the border with
North Korea sits Osan Air Base where
soldiers of the 35th air defense
Artillery Brigade routinely prepare
Patriot missiles to be fired in the
event of an attack so this is our pack 3
missile system where does it shoots the
missile and guides that missile to their
TV on so it's literally just hit to kill
Connecticut to kill that's what
this is the long-term yes the missiles
are fired off from the thing we're
looking at right now so literally I mean
the easiest way to put it out is our
launcher and our missiles hit their
missiles to bless it all this
but this is not been
when the cream is left
no not yet no yeah I mean depending on
we're ready to do it we need to so when
President Trump says that everything is
locked and loaded as you did just a
short while ago
is this what he's talking about I guess
so we're always ready you know
we're ready to fight tonight whether the
president United States says that we're
locked and loaded
we're our postures we're ready to fight
tonight at any one given time they're
ready to go I know the goal of the US
Army here is to maintain the Armistice
do you feel like the recent heated
rhetoric between President Trump and Kim
Jungman has made that job a little
harder I can't come on the same day we
visited the US bases crowds gathered in
Seoul to commemorate independence from
Japan and to urge peace with North Korea
in his Liberation Day speech president
moon jae-in said military action can
only be decided by South Korea and not
anyone else at the same time moon has
moved forward with installing the u.s.
built pad or terminal high altitude area
defense anti-ballistic missile system in
so summary a quiet agricultural village
that's now a symbol of resistance
anti-war activists believe the fad make
South Korea more vulnerable to attack
thousands have flocked here to support
the roughly one hundred elderly
villagers who say their peaceful lives
have been disrupted by the military
presence
[Music]
so we're hiking up the mountain right
now and it's gonna take us about an hour
to get to the top this isn't a mountain
that people normally climb this isn't a
path it's actually really strenuous but
the leader of the village created this
path to take news crews up to the top to
see the thaad and he marked it with
these blue ribbons that you could see
over here which are protesting the bad
it's from the top of the mountain where
you can see the fat which was installed
on a former golf course in the village
the area is also home to a cemetery and
a site sacred to Wan Buddhism but access
to both is now restricted the area has
been deemed a military zone the fad
works by detecting an incoming missile
and firing an interceptor missile to
destroy it its radar can identify
missiles hundreds of miles in range but
it's not physically designed to hit
fast-moving intercontinental ballistic
missiles like the ones North Korea
launched in July its developer Lockheed
Martin says the THAAD radar could at
least provide early tracking data of
long-range missiles like those headed
toward the u.s. those are Korean
soldiers that's the Korean army up there
guarding this spot
no film for the Korean soldiers telling
us this not we definitely weren't
expecting that
it was pretty surprising and obviously
really upsetting to our guide to get to
the top of the mountain which he's done
many times and then find the Korean
military they're telling him you can't
go anymore he was saying he doesn't
think they have any legal basis for that
so not only are these guys actively
protesting the presence of the US
military here now the Korean military
which works with America isn't even
letting him get to the top of the
mountain of their village so we're gonna
find another way Oh yogi pony car
chicken community chili McCoy say Oh
yogi Tonto Bharati peewee Donna Botti
military announcement again persnickety
[Music]
alright that was that was a second
military announcement we heard from the
South Korean army telling us to get out
of here so we don't want to get in any
trouble we're gonna do that and are you
okay not okay
siga yogi consultant on TV tomorrow
other theories Domino's has video for
now
larita yogi oh no gotta come to Delta
Bravo yogi look at them soon quality
retarded
some South Koreans have been protesting
the fad for over a year
[Music]
[Applause]
what just happened why are you laughing
right now are they uncle Gus okay Betsy
hollowness assuming total nerve and
abundant they commonly repair go to
monger that's an IR we are a proton pump
about me tonight ago so much me name is
iris hi panel her for dinner of the
fungal City Gail Thomas cometa energy
misery Akira is it all started back off
threatened in the back many of so
summaries villagers are farmers of Cham
way or Korean melon they remember the
horrors of the Korean War and thought
living in a rural area which shield them
from further conflict but now the tail
end of their lives is spent consumed by
fear and worry Jenna mom demand I work
week even better thanking help me woman
Otto Bayer there because I know losing
my man yeah many of the villagers have
become activists in their eighties you
know you happy now have only open I was
just with the US Army and they told me
that their presence in South Korea makes
this country safer
what do you say to them
we would enjoy move on we do not a lot
of Adam that is a liberal Rob I added
under she baked them she well yeah among
her other did it is the entrance to her
village is now a protest zone with
constant police presence as North Korea
continues to fire off missile tests and
the u.s. and South Korea flex their
military might
it's the people who are once again
caught in the crossfire
hey guys it's Dina thanks for watching
that video you got a glimpse of what the
US military is doing here in South Korea
and the Koreans that are opposing it
make sure you check out the next video
in this series and like share and
comment on this video